all right summer movie season officially
over so I wanted to bring you this movie
review of a movie it's a documentary
that you might not have heard about but
I think it's pretty awesome
so let's talk about indie game the movie
the hardest part about this is gonna be
trying to figure out how to title it
above is an indie game the movie movie
review cuz I always say movie review at
the end of my movie reviews it's pretty
redundant though so is it indie game the
movie review in which case it sounds
like it's called indie games uh and I
probably indie game the movie - movie
review I will figure it out later
so indie game the movie is a documentary
that follows a few indie game developers
if all those Edmund McMillen and Tommy
revenues they made Super Meat Boy and
Phil fish who made Fez it also features
Jonathan Blow but it doesn't follow him
because at this point in the movie when
the movie was being made raid was
already out it already come out and he
was like yeah it's commercial success
and the critical success because
everyone who's played the game loves it
I love this because all these different
personalities are ultimately looking for
something different in making their
games I mean these are the people who
make the games also super meatboy made
by two people Fez made by a dude this is
an EA with a Chilean projects on their
plate and if one sucks it again doesn't
matter it like 500 other things going on
that we also don't care about it does it
whatever these people are pouring
everything they have into these games
these are passion projects these are
this is their life work now a lot of
commercials except they all want to make
money at their game for sure other than
that they want something else also they
want commercial success and they want
you to buy their parents a house maybe
they want to connect with the gamer on a
deeper level and they didn't get that
maybe they want celebrity status or just
be able to make their game in a few
years without being hassled I like
Edmund and Tommy Edmund especially
because he's like you tell he was the
weird kid in school but he was just like
I'm just looking for an outlet he would
draw weird-ass [ __ ] in school and
doodles and the teachers were like he's
out of his mind he needs to be
psychologically evaluated and it brings
relevance to the old phrase sometimes a
serial killer in the making is just an
indie game developer looking for his
outlet and it touches on how gaming and
game developing has changed over the
years steam brought everything to the
level before steam you needed to work
for a company and have a boss and you
need to do this this and that and that
is there alright and then those
companies had to work with the retailers
because the retailers had power because
they're like oh we'll just not
distribute your game if you're a dick
and we don't like it or we just don't
like you in general or you slept with my
daughter who knows but Steam and Xbox
Live and PlayStation Network and all
minotaurs like hey if you're a game
developer you can just make this as many
of these people have shown us in this
movie you'll want to kill yourself
making it but you can do it it was
really neat after super meat boy gets
made you know it's a crazy success
little spoiler alert this is kind of a
spoiler alert all around because we all
know how these games have turned out
this is looking back this is a
retrospective this is the process of
seeing how it happened but Edmunds
online and he's on YouTube but he's
watching people played he's just dying
laughing cuz these people are like yeah
because Super Meat Boy is so insanely
hard he was just getting a kick out of
his look yeah it's supposed to be a
success I got what I wanted out of that
build faces the developer in this game
he's the one who made Fez he is the most
interesting to me he says his interview
in this movie that the lady who's
interviewing him she was like what will
you do if you don't make Fez and he's
like I will kill myself like that's my
motivation for making this game is so I
don't have to kill myself I was like oh
he's in this big legal battle with his
former partners taking him a few years
to make this game and everyone's just
haggled there on blogs like [ __ ] you
he's like I'm making it holy [ __ ] it's
just me I'm a dude I'm a one guy show
I'm one dude bringing you a pretty vast
game a pretty big game you can see the
stress is wearing on this guy this is
one scene where he is so irritated
because he's at PAX he's gonna present
the game but he can't because his former
partner he hasn't signed a legal
paperwork to release the game to him and
he just goes off on a tangent I was like
he's pissed and I really hope his former
partner doesn't miraculously
suspiciously end up dying sometime
because they're gonna suspect it like
yeah he did it he admitted on camera
that he would do it and it really is a
bummer knowing how Phil fish turned out
after Fez came out you know everyone
likes Fez he was making Fez tuned for
one reason or another some people say it
was you know development companies
although he was independent so I don't
know how it would be but they're saying
this is probably the most likely
scenario is that people were still
haggling him along oh right now Fez do
where is it dick he was like you know
what no Fez - I'm out I don't make games
anymore peace it really sucks I hate it
when trolls win but the trolls clearly
won with him and some people will be
like well Phillip fish was a dick you
know how many brilliant successful
revolutionary people throughout history
you would consider a dick if you talked
to them face to face right now you need
a break holy [ __ ] I just kind of see it
as if I spent five years making one
video like one deconstruction of
something I was really passionate about
in his [ __ ] light in the middle of a
great monologue
holy [ __ ] timing there as I was saying
if I made one video for five years now I
was just hammering into it it was all my
passion everything I had I poured into
it people were just like where is it
where is it where is it where is it did
make it and I release it and people's
response generally speaking the public
we're like alright well where's the next
one douche I'd probably just leave
YouTube I'd be like it's not worth it so
I understand where he's coming from it
just sucks to see it happen I really
love indie game the movie honestly maybe
it's because I like game so the school
scene behind the curtain of how it
happens I feel like if you're a gamer
you should watch this movie if you like
any games you should watch this movie if
you're interested in making indie games
you should definitely watch this movie
cuz it's not cut and dry so I'm like oh
yeah anyone can do it here let's make an
indie game it's no they all at some
point wanted to quit they were like yeah
no worth it I love seeing the people who
made these games I like knowing how it
all turned out it's kind of like the
spoiler of real life and you knowing
what happened after this movie is makes
it more fun looking back on the genesis
of these guys before their success and
it's just real I wonder how did they
pick these people that like all right
we're picking these people and rolling
the dice oh they're gonna be successful
in they happen to be successful or do
they pick like 20 people developing
games they're like we're gonna follow
all these people and then whoever
actually makes it will put them in the
movie I don't know all i know is indie
game the movies one of my favorite
documentaries I can pop it in at any
time watch it have a good time with it I
sympathize with these indie game
developers I look up to them I admire
them because the indie game the movie is
awesome tacular
20 on the release date of this huge-ass
game it just came out today I'm like
indie game the movie indeed good I still
your favorite indie game what is it
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]